dear ukrainians  this morning president putin announced a  special military operation in the  donbass russia carried out strikes on  our military infrastructure on our  border guards explosions were heard in  many cities of ukraine we introduced  martial law throughout the state a  minute ago i had a conversation with  president biden the u.s is starting to  gather international support  today we need you each of you to be calm  if possible stay at home please we are  working the army is working the entire  security and defense sector of ukraine  is working  i the national security and defence  council the government will be in touch  soon i will be in touch again  do not panic we are strong we are ready  for everything and we will defeat  everyone because we are ukraine  glory to ukraine  so green slavogreen